والاوضاع الميدانيه للمعارك في اوكرانيا
تشهد تصعيدا مستمرا في مختلف الجبهات
ابرزها باخمه التي يتواصل فيها القتال منذ
اسابيع موسكو تواصل سعيها الحثيث للسيطره
على باخمت حيث تحاصرها من جهات متعدده ما
يشعل المعارك من حولها وهو ما اكده قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الذي قال ان الوضع في محيط مدينه باقمت
اصبح متوترا للغايه الجنرال الاوكرانيه
اوضح ايضا ان القوات الروسيه دفعت بوحدات
هجوميه تابعه لمجموعه في محاوله لاختراق
دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني بهدف فرض حصار على
المدينه وهذا ولم تتوقف الهجمات الروسيه
الاخيره عند حدود ضخمه بل امتدت الى شرق
خركيز ولمن ايضا نقلا عن الجيش الاوكراني
الذي اشار الى انه احبط 60 هجوم الروسيا
خلال 24 ساعه